-Welcome to the show!
I'm so happy to have you here.
-I've never been
to your house before.
-You have never been here.
How do you like it so far?
-Oh, it's nice.
-Oh, good.
-Really ni --
Hi, y'all!
-I want to --
I want to say something,
because I don't
want you to think
that we waited until you got a
star on Hollywood's Walk of Fame
to have you on the show.
-Oh, you didn't?
-We did not.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It just so happens
that you just got a star
on Hollywood's Walk of Fame.
Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I will tell everybody,
on Hollywood Boulevard,
my star is right --
Listen.
I thought it was gonna be right
in front of the Pantages.
But guess where it is.
Hmm?
Right in front of the CVS!
Oh, it's lovely.
-That's fantastic.
-Yes.
You can get gum and cold cream
and then visit my star!
-That's great.
You gave a phone
to one of your friends?
'Cause I know you had friends
and family out there,
co-workers.
-Yeah.
-And you seem very happy
about your star.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, you --
I came to check on my star.
Okay?
It's still right here.
It's not dirty yet.
Nobody has drawn on it
or anything.
We doin' good.
I wanna sleep here!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Congratulations.
-Yeah.
I stayed out there a while.
-You stayed out there a while?
-Because I wanted --
I didn't want anybody to step
on it so it would get dirty,
so I just kind of
directed traffic.
"Move around, people!"
-Yeah.
'Cause I wonder how --
it must be --
for a tourist in Hollywood,
it must be so exciting
to see both the star
on the ground
and then the actual star
guarding it.
[ Laughter ]
-I had to take a lot of photos.
-You had to take
a lot of photos.
-I had to take a lot of photos.
-Congratulations
on "Claws," as well.
-Thank you!
-You just got picked up
for a third season.
-I did.
-That's amazing. Well done.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank all of you!
-So, you -- you play one of the
many women who work in a salon.
They do nail art.
They give manicures.
And you guys all --
you went to nail school.
Is that what --
What would you call it?
-Yeah, we -- no, we all
had to go to nail school.
-It is called nail school.
-That's what they call it.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
We all had to learn
how to do nails.
My character, specifically,
had to also learn
how to thread eyebrows.
-Okay.
-Now, I'm on the show
with Carrie Preston, Judy Reyes,
Karrueche Tran, and Jenn Lyon.
And I lovingly say,
if all of the nail salons
ended in the world, the women
from "Claws," we got you.
-Really? You're that good?
-Oh, yeah.
-Now, how long did you have
to go to nail school?
Was it -- Was it intensive?
-I had to go to nail school
for two whole weeks.
-Wow!
I'm very impressed.
-You thought
I was gonna say years?
No, just --
Just two weeks.
-I was willing to guess days, so
I'm very impressed with weeks.
And was there anybody --
was there a standout
among the -- of your cast?
-You're looking at her.
[ Laughter ]
-You were the --
You were the best?
The show is on TNT, so,
you know, it's a cable show.
You get away with some stuff
that maybe you wouldn't
get on network TV.
You've done some pretty
outrageous stuff.
Is there things that you are --
are shocked that you get to do,
or happy you get to do?
-You mean like have sex?
-There's a lot of sex
on the show.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of sex
on the show.
-I am shocked
by when it happened.
Because, you know,
one would think,
if somebody was gonna ask you
to play a sexy character
or be some sort of a vixen,
maybe you in your 20s
or in your 30s.
They didn't ask me to do it
until I got in my 40s.
I'm like, "What is happening?"
[ Laughter ]
"Now?!"
-Yeah!
You're incredible.
It's an incredible compliment.
I think that's great.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
You sighed like
you're too tired for it now.
[ Laughter ]
-No, but here's the thing.
We film in New Orleans,
and it --
They have the best food
in the world.
And my jump suits on the show
are so incredibly tight.
-Right. I see.
-And so, it is,
you know, every day.
I just, I feel like a can of
biscuits ready to pop.
[ Laughter ]
-That is very unfair.
That is very unfair to film it
somewhere where the food
is delicious.
-Very unfair!
-This is very exciting.
In an earlier episode, we got
to see you as a young woman.
And so, obviously,
they had to cast an actress
to play you
when you were younger.
And they cast your --
your daughter.
-My real-life daughter.
-Your real-life daughter.
-Yeah.
-And I gotta say -- Dia?
Is that her name?
-Dia, yeah.
-It makes sense.
You guys look a lot alike.
-Well, it makes sense
until I say,
"Baby, there is an audition,
and, you know --
but to play a young me,
and would you like
mommy to help you?
Let me help you."
So, what she said, "Oh, no.
I got an acting coach.
I'm good."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "But it's me."
I mean, you're playing me.
And let me help you.
"Oh, no, no.
I'ma go to my acting coach.
I'll be fine."
[ Laughter ]
So, I didn't get to see
her tape or anything.
She did everything by herself.
-Wow.
-So, I was sad
because I wasn't a part of it
but happy because
she took the initiative
and did it on her own,
so good girl.
-And she actually
had to audition for it.
-Yeah! Oh, yeah.
-Oh, good for her.
-Oh, yeah.
-Good for her.
-No, I don't give out freebies.
-Yeah, no.
-I don't give out freebies.
I'm like,
"No, you gotta work for it."
-Yeah.
You earned your star.
She's gonna earn her star.
-That part.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
You --
And she is about --
You're gonna be
an empty-nester soon, right?
-Soon. You know, we got three
out, and she's the last one in.
But I did move her bedroom --
I mean, not her bedroom,
but her actual bed
right by the front door.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I want her to know,
time is ticking.
-The time is ticking.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, yes, I want to walk
around in my house naked.
I got a --
[ Laughter ]
This is a lot to unleash
in the house
with other people in there,
y'all.
Okay! I need the kids out,
'cause my husband is there.
We got things to do.
-Yeah.
How quickly --
Well, do you think
you'll actually
hear the door close
before you're both completely
naked when she leaves, or...?
-Man, it's hard
for me to keep clothes on now.
[ Laughter ]
My husband is like,
"Knock it off, lady.
Go put something on."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, congratulations,
in advance, on when that happens
and on the show
and on your star.
And thank you so much
for being here, Niecy.
-Thank you!